le président mitterrand et le chancelier
kohl qui se serrent la main pendant la
marseillaise
à
ah ah
l'image probablement la plus poignante
de cette cérémonie le président
mitterrand et le chancelier kohl se
serrant la main pendant l'exécution de
la marseillaise après que le deutschland
über alles assez retenti sur ces lieux
historiques je crois que c'est la
première fois que l'hymne allemand était
jouée à verdun une poignée de main 25
ans après les accords conclus entre le
général de gaulle et monsieur conrad
adenauer qui scellait la réconciliation
franco-allemande une réconciliation qui
est effective maintenant et que maurice
genevoix